Good evening, my name is Alan Bernstein
and I'm the President and CEO of CIFAR.
Imagine that later this evening some
aliens are going to visit us here at the
Artscape Daniel's launchpad from
another planet. Imagine that they
immediately demand to know what is our
most proud achievement
what are our proudest accomplishments?
what would we say?
Well of course being at an Arts Center, we
could cite the words of Bach, Stravinksi,
the group of seven, Shakespeare, Picasso.
Yet would these beautiful works be
understood or even appreciated by other
sentient beings with experiences and
worlds unimaginably different from our
own? After all, even when Picasso started
doing his cubist paintings, other humans
failed to appreciate his art. And when
Stravinsky's Rite of Spring was first
performed, the audience fled from the hall.
Why then, would we expect aliens to
appreciate our own artistic accomplishments?
But there is one area of human accomplishment of which we can rightly boast.
It is the one achievement
that reflects the unique power of the
human brain and our curiosity about the
world around us. And it is why our
species is called Homo sapiens, which
means wise humans. And that achievement,
that uniquely human achievement, is
called science. Science has explained
much about the history and the mystery
of the universe. The physical laws that
govern all matter, the mechanisms of
heredity and soon, an understanding of
how we think and feel. And the fruits of
science have transformed our
world in myriads of ways. Consider
smallpox.
Smallpox killed approximately 300 million people in the 20th century.
In this century no one will die of smallpox. No one. That's science.
The fruits of science have also doubled our
lifespan as Canadians since
Confederation.
Doubled our lifespans since Confederation.
Science has made it
possible to light and heat our homes.
Science has saved over 1 billion lives
due to vaccines and antibiotics in the 20th century.
Science has provided
evidence-driven changes in social policy.
Scientific research has been a catalyst
for equity-based social movements,
including a woman's right to vote,
education for all, and healthcare for all in many countries.
We truly live in an age defined by, and transformed by science.
That's why I have the best job
in Canada.
In fact I think I have the best job in the world.
As CIFAR's president and as a scientist,
I oversee a global network of the world's
very top scientists, their collaborators,
our partners, and our donors, who together are transforming our understanding of
the biological, the physical, and the
social worlds in which we live.
And in the process, are transforming our world.
That's what I call impact.
CIFAR convenes the world's top scientists to address
complex questions
such as, how does our childhood experiences and/or our
socioeconomic status affect our
trajectory of lifelong health?
How do microbes that live in and on us, our microbiome,
affect our health, human
evolution, and our behaviour?
What can nature teach us about
harvesting and storing energy from the Sun?
How can we understand the molecular
underpinnings of human intelligence?
What is consciousness?
Why are some societies
successful, and others not?
These are all examples of CIFAR programs that are
going on at the very moment.
But science is much, much more than that.
Put simply, it is the best way that
humanity has come up with to understand
and improve the world in which we live.
Science creates revolutions and
revelations that echo right across generations.
But scientific discoveries
have not only advanced our understanding
of the world. They have lifted the veil
of ignorance, superstition, and terror
that has characterized much of
humanity's experiences before science.
Today science is addressing the great challenges our world is facing.
Those challenges, to name
but a few, include terrorism, food and water security,
mental health, infectious
disease - think of Covid 19 - and of course
the climate crisis to name but a few are
global
and they all require scientific research for their solution.
and that's where CIFAR comes in.
As a Canadian-based, global organization, we convene the world's top scientists
400 of them, at the moment, from 23 countries
who work together
across disciplines to address the
solutions needed to address the most
important questions facing science and humanity.
CIFAR was founded on a
disarmingly simple idea.
The best way to address the important questions of our time
is to bring together the best people,
across disciplines and borders, to
engage in deep thinking and discussions
about their solutions. We identify big,
complex, and challenging questions and
then identify the very best scientists
from anywhere in the world to work on
those questions. We create a safe space
where brilliant minds come together to
form global communities, challenge each
other as colleagues,
forge new collaborations across disciplines, that hopefully change the world's thinking
about an important question. That simple
idea led to the current breakthrough in
artificial intelligence, our understanding of the importance of the early years,
and insights into the central role that strong
institutions play in economic growth.
Consider artificial intelligence for a moment - AI.
About 20 years ago CIFAR
brought together a very small group of
mathematicians, computer scientists,
neurophysiologists, and cognitive
psychologists, with the goal to
understand how humans learn.
Over the decades that followed, that CIFAR team developed new insights that resulted in
deep learning and the revolution in AI
taking place around the world.
Yes, AI is a Canadian breakthrough
and we are all reaping the benefits of that "made in Canada" discovery
through the high-tech explosion taking place here in Toronto,
Montreal, and Edmonton and across
the country.
And the CIFAR Azrieli Global Scholars Program,
supported by the Azrieli Foundation and Nancy and John Love,
identifies the world's most
promising young scientists and provides
the funds and mentorship they need to
launch their successful careers.
Because of science we live longer, we suffer less and we enjoy lives
that were unimaginable even a hundred years ago.
We have learned to advance and apply knowledge,
robust knowledge, not acquired
by superstition or myth, but by science
and evidence, to improve the human
condition.
And that's why investments in science always has impact.
Science is indeed the light that illuminates the
darkness in the world by advancing our
understanding of the world.
And science reflects the very best of our humanity.
The use of our brain and our curiosity
to understand the world around us.
It is this curiosity, this insistence on
the challenging of dogma and belief, I
think, that would impress those
extraterrestrial visitors that we're all
going to meet later on this evening.
I encourage you to think about how science
has made an impact on your own life.
From the last time you used your cell phone,
to flipping a switch to turn on a light
to the flu vaccine that I hope you all
got, to a loved one who is alive because
of scientific research. The donors who
support CIFAR are truly impressive because
they understand that despite the long
timelines involved, the impact of science
on our lives is staggering. Science has
truly changed our world.
They understand that if you want impact, if you want to change the world, you can do no better
than to invest in science and in CIFAR.
Thank you for your attention.